[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans l'europe
hebdo c'est parti pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne l'union
européenne à 60 ans samedi dernier elle
fêté son anniversaire à rome un
anniversaire à 27
alors que le divorce avec la grande
bretagne est entamée quel avenir pour
l'union européenne
est ce une vieille dame en fin de vie ou
une adolescente en pleine crise et qu'en
pensent nos voisins italiens
reportage à rome tout à l'heure mais
d'abord retour sur les festivités d'un
anniversaire célébré en grande pompe
malgré la crise avec aurélie la face
[Musique]
sous le soleil italien
c'est un anniversaire particulier pour
l'europe il ya 60 ans jour pour jour
était signé le traité de rome six états
s'engagent est à établir les fondements
d'une union qu'ils voulaient sans cesse
plus étroite entre l'époque aujourd'hui
l'adhésion populaire fait défaut et il
s'agit plutôt de donner un nouveau
départ à une union européenne en plein
doute
les représentants des états membres sont
parvenus à un accord au dernier moment
greg les polonais menaçait de ne pas
signer le texte
finalement les états s'engagent à agir
de concert
si nécessaire à des rythmes différents
et avec une intensité différente tout en
avançant dans la même direction
une autre façon de signifier que
l'europe progressera désormais à
plusieurs vitesses dans une union à
géométrie variable
la déclaration de rome est aussi le
premier grand texte signé sans le
royaume uni la première ministre
britannique theresa may n'avait pas fait
le déplacement à rome avant même la
notification officielle du brds excite
auprès des autorités européennes
alors en plein divorce cet accord sera
t-il suffisant pour relancer l'europe à
cet accord sera t-il suffisant pour
relancer l'europe à 27 est pour en
débattre je reçois viviane reding
bonjour bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne membre du groupe ppe au sein
de ce parlement vous êtes
luxembourgeoise et vous êtes ancienne
vice-présidente de la commission
européenne c'est bien ça en face de vous
sait s'il tient gay bonjour vous êtes
députée européenne socialiste et
démocrate italienne et vous êtes ancien
ministre de l'intégration du
gouvernement des tricots à l'état enfin
à côté de vos jean sébastien lefebvre
vous êtes journaliste ou portails
d'information contexte spécialisé sur
les politiques françaises et européennes
première question viviane reding on a vu
les festivités autour de ses 60 ans du
traité de rome ce samedi donc à rome
vous y étiez
quelques jours quelques jours avant
alors que theresa may a notifié donc ce
break cible qu'on attendait déjà depuis
quelques mois
est-ce que c'est pas un peu un mantra y
quand on a vu tous ces chefs d'état
signé est-ce que c'est pas une manière
de se dire finalement que on va
continuer l'europe même si elle n'a
jamais été aussi en crise
ben 60 ans ça se fête quand une femme un
homme atteint l'âge de 60 ans il ya une
grande fête avec les amis comptent une
des aventures humaines les plus
extraordinaires
fédérer des états qui avance faisait
pendant des siècles la guerre et avoir
60 ans de paix fête ses 60 ans on l'a
commémore et c'était sa robe n'est plus
ni moins même si cécile king et theresa
may qui est absente en fait de cet
anniversaire c'est quand même un symbole
dramatique pour l'union européenne
oui c'est un peu dramatique puisque
c'est la première fois que un état
membre décide de quitter l'union
européen donc je crois que c'est 60 ans
qu'on a fêté il ya quelque chose qui a
marqué deux points de vue négatifs un
peu cette fête puisque moi je crois
qu'on devrait normalement essayer de
fêter tous ensemble donc 27 +1 c'est un
peu triste c'était mieux si on fêtait à
donc aujourd'hui c'est une vraie crise
en europe c'est une crise de solidarité
entre les différents états membres c'est
pourquoi je crois que cette fête là
aurait eu un peu plus de courage
même dans
le compromis qu'ils ont trouvé et c'est
ça qu'il faut dire donc l'europe
normalement on doit trouver encore plus
de courage pour repartir
j'espère qu'on va repartir avec ses 60
ans jean sébastien lefebvre l'idée c'est
de repartir mais repartir vers quoi
ajustements dans la déclaration
rome c'est très flou c'est à dire que
connaît fallu trouver quelque chose qui
conviennent aussi bien à l'europe de
l'ouest qu'à l'est nord sud
surtout les polonais ou les grecs comme
c'était mentionné dans dans le petit
reportage on voit pas trop où est ce
qu'ils veulent il n'y a pas de projet
dans le texte qu'elles soient là on est
une liane je le reste voilà là il va
falloir la la la la la la craie et
surtout tout le monde se dit il faudra
attendre la fin du calendrier législatif
orale en europe et en france et en
allemagne avant l'heure émerger quelque
chose de concret viviane reding quelque
chose de concret une vision pour l'heure
comment se fait-il que il ya aussi peu
de vision aussi peu de souffle dans
cette construction européenne surtout vu
la crise qu'on traverse
ben c'était allait tellement bien
pendant des dizaines d'années que à
chaque fois qu'il y avait un réveil qui
sonnait on me mettait sauce nous tant
qu'ils ne nous réveille pas or je crois
que le break si tu as fait que les gens
se sont dit on ne peut pas continuer
comme par le passé
il faut qu'ils allaient heureux créer
cette europe si nécessaire à
quelques-uns donc faire une europe
autour d'un centre guy veuille avancées
en matière humanitaire et europe
différente qui est l'europe à plusieurs
vitesses
l'europe à plusieurs vitesses est encore
autre chose mais disons que les pays qui
veulent vraiment partage et la
solidarité partagé une vision politique
faire une europe plus solidaire plus
sociale et bien qu'ils avancent ensemble
et que les autres
regarde hameau de loi alors donc theresa
may a notifié enfin le break cité après
près de dix mois d'atermoiements et
d'attentes jean sébastien lefebvre
qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant
est ce que l'europe comme on a pu le
voir ce samedi va réussir à être unie
face à ces négociations qui s'avère
particulièrement difficile
est ce qu'ils vont réussir ça on sait
pas l'avenir nous le dira mais ils ont
tout intérêt parce qu' une des
stratégies de la diplomatie britannique
et bien sûr d'essayer de diviser les
européens en disant voilà vous avez des
intérêts différents moi je peux vous
promettre ça à titre individuel donc les
si les européens sont pas unis le plus
grand risque c'est qu'à la fin on
détricote toute une partie de l'acquis
communautaire sur lequel s'est construit
l'union européenne dont ce serait une
défaite politique pour l'union
mais là on va rentrer dans une longue
phase de négociations ça va durer deux
ans il y aura des rebondissements les
britanniques peuvent aussi se braquer on
sait pas
l'union européenne veut lui réclamé 60
milliards donc est-ce qu'ils vont
repasser milliards en fait pour être
clair qu'ils sont en fait normalement ce
qu'elle doit payer dans le cadre du
budget pluriannuel qui a été votée avant
que le break site donc ne soit décelé
exactement c'est un peu l'addition du
restaurant vous pouvez partir avant la
fin de la soirée mais il faut payer
l'addition avant de partir et donc voit
donc est ce que les européens vont
arriver à tenir la ligne pour l'instant
oui même s'il se dispute entre sur
comment relancer lieu face au royaume
uni pour l'instant ça va à peu près
facile qu'à muguet vous est confiante
vous disiez qu'il ya un manque de
courage de la part des européens
est ce que dans le cadre des
négociations sur le break sites dont qui
s'annonce il ya une possibilité qui est
une division qui risque de faire
imploser l'union européenne bon ça ce
sont des risques mais je crois que la
grande bretagne n'a pas raconté la
vérité à ses citoyens et citoyennes donc
le break site est arrivé il cependant
raconté beaucoup de mensonges et surtout
que nous sommes en train de faire face
au fait qu news les forces nouvelles qui
sont une menace pour la démocratie c'est
ce qui s'est passé par exemple sur le
bre citer aussi sur d'autres élections
donc aujourd'hui la difficulté qu'il ya
et qu'il ya des dirigeants c'est à dire
les leaders politiques qui a pris une
autre chose c'est-à-dire la sortie hors
de l'union européenne
il y a
la population qui ne veut pas quitter
l'union européenne il faut le rappeler
il y a les causes qui en train de
demander un nouveau référendum
donc le réseau si oui ou non il ya une
difficulté donc je crois que ces deux
années qui vont suivre ça sera vraiment
difficile pour dix ans pour pour londres
de faire comprendre ses motivations pour
pouvoir sortir de mon côté c'est une
grande erreur puisque nous sommes dans
une période où de vendée des pays comme
la chine les etats unis c'est à dire des
grands pays des pays
dès qu'ils sont en train de venir des
grandes puissances on ne peut parler la
barre divisé on doit nécessairement
faire en état fédéral c'est à dire moi
je suis pour un état fédéral par exemple
de plus de 70 de 500 millions de
personnes qui devient une force et une
forte puissance au niveau mondial sans
ça nous sommes vraiment très faible
niveau qu'on s'en rende compte
viviane reding ce break site donc qui
s'énonce le risque c'est quoi ce qui en
effet domino non parce que ce qu'on a vu
lorsque les gens ont commencé à
comprendre ce que ça veut dire break
site je suis d'accord avec vous une
grande erreur politique et une bêtise en
fait une très grande bêtise les les
sondages montrent que y compris en
france d'ailleurs
les gens croient plus en l'europe parce
qu'ils ont compris ce que vous venez
d'expliquer que plus on sera petit plus
les autres continents vont nous imposer
leur point de vue plus on sera grand et
fort plus les prochaines générations
peuvent prendre leurs décisions
autonomes et ne pas se laisser imposer
par la chine demain par exemple leur
manière de vivre
donc les dents le eurobaromètre les
français à 67% maintenant pense que
l'union européenne est une bonne chose
les allemands à 81% il ya eu 20 % de
points de plus depuis quelques années
lorsque les gens voient ce qui se
passait il ya quand même donc selon vous
un attachement à l'europe pourtant on
voit bien que
l'union européenne telle qu'elle
fonctionne aujourd'hui est de plus en
plus rejetée alors on voit en france on
le voit aux pays bas on l'a vu en grande
bretagne on a justement voulu voir à
rome
là où se sont déroulés donc les
festivités pour les 60 ans le sentiment
européen on a voulu voir un petit peu
comment est-ce que les romains voyait
cette europe à quelques jours de ses
festivités reportage avant le sommet de
sanya de chiens
[Musique]
il ya 60 ans l'union européenne signe
est ici son acte fondateur sous le
capitole de rome 6 pays scellé leur
destin commun et posé les bases de ce
qui allait devenir l'union européenne
six décennies plus tard rome est
désormais dirigé par une eurosceptiques
virginia rajhi du mouvement cinq étoiles
a pris la tête de la ville en 2016 et
l'anniversaire du traité de rome semble
bien éloignée des préoccupations des
romains salue les fiches pas vous les
faits un sticker pour la marche pour
l'europe à la haye ce midi marina et les
jeunes du mouvement fédéraliste sont
venus tracter devant la faculté de
sciences politiques il tente de
convaincre les étudiants de participer à
une manifestation pour fêter
l'anniversaire du traité de rome tient à
tous n'en veux pas tu ne viendras mais
même auprès d'étudiants très politisée
l'événement ne soulève pas vraiment l'
enthousiasme ils ignorent totalement
l'événement ils ignorent
au delà de la manif que nous on est en
train d'organiser il ignore totalement
la comment dire la date la date
symbolique et ils me répondent aussi que
je suis utopiste folle que j'y crois
mais que je devrais pas y croire que de
ça sans l'europe ne sert à rien comme
marina adriano se sont profondément
propre et en mai il se bat pour une
autre europe
il voudrait bien dit fier complètement
l'europe l'on voudrait une europe plus
démocratique et que les citoyens aient
vraiment la possibilité de choisir de
déterminer les politiques
il a beau tracter avec enthousiasme
l'europe l'aide des cieux une union
économique n'a jamais été prolongé par
l'intégration politique
caillaud capistes rocard bien moi je
comprends ceux qui sont fâchés et europe
moi même je me suis je voudrais une
europe ne différent pas favorable à
l'europe telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
non mais je ne veux pas croire le choix
s'entendre intégrations européennes
puissent être jetés à la poubelle comme
sabine et justin on est face à un moment
historique dans le sens que aujourd'hui
l'europe à s'y arrêter
elle elle n'arrive plus à avancer
peut-être en france ou dans d'autres
pays européens
les crises ne sont pas perçus de la même
façon en italie on efface vraiment à une
crise sociale
mais aujourd'hui je pense que la seule
réponse est celle de croire encore plus
en une union européenne plus forte que
celle qu'on connaît
dans une italie où le taux de chômage
des jeunes dépasse les 35 %
l'euroscepticisme gagne du terrain
la monnaie est sans doute le symbole
physique le plus visible de
l'intégration européenne
mais de tous les pays de la zone euro
l'italie est celui où sa mise en
circulation a été la plus douloureuse
son contrôle de l'augmentation des prix
les italiens ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat
a chuté avec la nouvelle monia el sa
veuve et sa sauce passage à l'euro a été
désastreux parce que ni les retraites ni
les salaires n'augmentent et autant que
l'euro les prix ont doublé et la vie a
changé après cette augmentation
on n'était pas prêt à ce changement on
s'y retrouver dans une situation qui
nous amenait des problèmes pourtant sur
ce marché du quartier populaire de
monteverdi peu serait prêt à quitter
l'union monétaire
maintenant les risques et les mots pour
dire ce serait fier on risquerait de
s'appauvrir davantage en sortant de
l'eau relaté
isolé commercialement et politiquement
de beaucoup de choses il est désormais
trop tard pour sortir de la zone euro
espagne aurait une stagnation économique
et le mékong pas quitter neil soit prête
pour cette année c'est volontaire comme
tedjar les mecs qu'elle vit d'alger epal
italique va sortir de l'euro c'est tout
le monde parce que chacun doit retourner
à sa propre souveraineté - organiser un
référendum pour sortir de l'euro c'est
l'une des propositions du mouvement 5
étoiles ce parti eurosceptique dénonce
une europe dirigée par le couple franco
allemand
il est aujourd'hui en tête des sondages
l'italie pourrait elle alors comme le
royaume uni choisir un jour de quitter
l'union européenne est allée népal
le royaume uni nous sommes beaucoup plus
ancrée dans l'union européenne que
le royaume uni il ya quand même toujours
un support autour de 50% même moment le
plus bas de support pro-européen de la
part des deux italiens
donc je ne vois pas vraiment un parcours
de sortir de l'italie l'union européenne
en italie comme ailleurs l'union
européenne a déçu
mais soixante ans après la signature du
traité de rome les italiens se sentent
toujours européen plutôt que quitter
l'union
il semble surtout vouloir la changer
cécile king s est assez étonnant en fait
ce qu'on vient d'entendre
on ne veut pas quitter l'europe et
viviane reding nous le disait il ya un
véritable attachement pourtant l'idée
c'est de la changer
c'est quoi la priorité pour changer
l'europe maintenant moi la première
chose ça serait plus de justice sociale
puisque si vous avez bien regardé il ya
le chômage soit le chômage des jeunes et
des chômeurs des gens donc il faut créer
un hôtel d'emplois puisque l'europe a
été confrontée à plusieurs crises la
première crise qui est la prise la crise
économique la deuxième c'est nacry sur
la sécurité puisque après les attentats
de paris nice et j'en passe le peuple
européen a commencé à avoir peur
donc il a un peu d'informations sur les
gens qui arrivent en europe il ya peu
d'informations et tous ceux qui
regardent le fait qu news uniformes des
forces informations ça donne influence
de l'impact sur des gens qui sont déjà
en vigueur ce sitting et comment est ce
qu on réoriente neurones
oui moi je crois que l'on doit rentrer à
l'article 80 du traité de fonctionnement
de l'union européenne plus de solidarité
entre les états des différents états
membres et surtout partage équitable des
responsabilités ça a beaucoup manqué du
point de vue dix ans une personne ne
veut céder une partie de sa souveraineté
mais tous veulent conserver leur pouvoir
donc il faut que chacun puisse céder
quelque peu lâché
oui exactement de médecins au centre
donc solidarité partage équitable des
responsabilités même du point de vue
financier même sur des thèmes qu'ils
regardent immigration question
économique mais aussi sur défense et
politique extérieure donc si chacun de
ses états membres laissent une partie de
sa souveraineté
moi je pars qu'on irait vers une europe
très forte une europe unie et vers une
même vision
est-ce que c'est pas utopiste un peu
viviane reding de se dire on va faire
plus d'europe encore alors que beaucoup
de gens en fait aujourd'hui se disent il
faut en sortir car l'europe n'a pas été
capable de nous protéger
elle n'a pas été à la hauteur et en plus
elle n'est pas transparente
j'ai été aussi sur une place aux as rome
et j'ai parlé avec les citoyens et
j'arrive un peu à la même conclusion que
votre journaliste c'est à dire les
et les gens ont un problème avec
l'europe en tant qu'institution mais
quand on continue à discuter avec eux
ils voudraient plus d'europe mais pas
sur les institutions sur des projets
très concrets
par exemple les sondages nous montre que
dans toute l'europe unie et bien
82% des citoyens voudraient que l'europe
prenne en main leur sécurité soit plus
fort plus uni plus efficace pour
combattre la criminalité pour combattre
le terrorisme c'est la raison pour
laquelle aussi il imagine que l'europe
soit plus forte à vers l'extérieur donc
une défense européenne
une véritable politique étrangère
européenne ce sont les gens eux mêmes
qui le demandent
la deuxième demande et celle liée à la
crise économique
ils voudraient que leur travail plus
contre le chômage
ils ne se rendent pas compte que ces
politiques là sont des politiques
nationales
donc les citoyens ça ne les intéresse
pas traitée ici traités là où il
voudrait de l'action et de la fiq a cité
troisième élément c'est très important
aussi pour plus de d'actions contre
l'évasion fiscale ça les touche
énormément
ça c'est quelque chose aussi donc si
nous regardons un peu ce que les gens
nous disent sans connaître ce qui est
possible de faire au niveau européen
il faudrait pour beaucoup de ces
politiques plus d'europe plus de
cohésion plus d'action on n'arrivera pas
à le faire à 27 c clair évident on vient
de voir récemment que la pologne vient
de dire qu'elle va quitter leur corps il
a tenu à dire cette coordination entre
les armées européennes donc on voit que
certaines choses avec certains ne seront
pas possible alors que ceux qui sont de
bonne volonté
ceux qui ont une responsabilité pour
l'avenir de leurs jeunes générations se
mettent ensemble pour fonctionner
finalement sur les demandes
des citoyens et qui sont assez cohérente
ses demandes
jean sébastien lefebvre l'enjeu c'est ça
donc réussir à avancer sur des points
clés en fait qui seront visibles par les
européens
emploi sécurité lutte contre le
terrorisme lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale
est-ce que ça suffit c'est déjà ce
qu'ils ont décidé il ya six mois de ça
quand ils ont commencé à faire les
sommets à 27 cents au royaume uni il
voulait avancer sur certains points et
des livres qu'ils lisent des livres et
des actions concrètes aux citoyens le
vrai qu'on sent seul consensus qui
existe vraiment c'est sur la question
des frontières extérieures leurs
renforcements la question la question
des garde-corps ça ça avance après sur
les autres sujets types défense vision
fiscale ou autre c'est très compliqué
parce qu'on touche à des compétences
régaliennes des états et les états
aujourd'hui clairement n'ont pas envie
de transférer de nouvelles compétences
ont pas envie d'aller plus loin même si
effectivement pour ça fonctionne mieux
mais rémy de l'europe finalement c'est
les états sérieux qu'ils ont créé c'est
tout le paradoxe c'est eux qui l'ont
créée c'est parfois eux qui créent avec
les crises parce que il refuse d'aller
jusqu'au bout de leur logique qu'ils ont
commencé la zone euro typiquement si on
voulait vraiment qu'elle fonctionne
mieux il y aurait toute une série de
réformes à faire organiser des
transferts financiers entre les pays
pourrait qu'il y aurait comme on fait
dans les pays au niveau des régions mais
sauf que ça ça impliquerait que certains
payent pour d'autres et aujourd'hui avec
l'étape des opinions publiques
et effectivement le manque de courage de
certains hommes politiques c'est pas
possible
et donc on continue à voir des pays qui
souffrent de leur appartenance à la zone
euro alors que d'autres en profitent un
peu plus s'ajouteraient aussi à la crise
ce qu'on appelle la crise des réfugiés
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est un grand défi
donc je suis d'accord avec le parisien
le sud mais a aussi une autre solution
qu'il faut donner à ces comment gérer et
comment avoir une politique commune sur
immigration et asile
ça c'est un point très délicat parmi les
états membres qui en provoque justement
qui nous fait voir la faiblesse de la
solidarité entre les différents états
membres
ce qu'on a vu en plus pendant la crise
grecque également la question de la
solidarité entre les états membres sur
la crise des réfugiés mais également
aussi quelques années auparavant sur la
crise des dettes souveraines et sur la
crise grecque sur la la phrase que vous
avez dit que en fait vous l'avez dit par
boutade le problème d
de l'europe ce sont les états membres
oui et pour ça la sortie de la
grande-bretagne peut être une chance
parce que si on analyse sur combien de
dossiers où on voulait avancer ensemble
la grande bretagne a mis les freins
c'est énorme
moi je suis pas certain que moi le
simple départ des britanniques va
résoudre ce problème là parce que chez
de nombreux pays en fait on sent une
réticence à l'europe on sent des
dirigeants qui ont hérité de la
construction européenne mais savent pas
trop quoi en faire et est par exemple
sur la question la taxe sur les
transactions financières qui est en
travaux depuis quatre ans cinq ans
maintenant on n'a que onze pays au
départ qui ont souhaité y participer
sont plus que 9
les britanniques ne sont pas dedans et
les pays qui bloque c'est avant tout la
belgique et les pays-bas des membres
fondateurs qui étaient là en 57 et donc
du coup les britanniques étaient souvent
très utile effectivement parce que
c'était les plus les ce qui paraît le
plus fort pour dire qu'ils étaient
contre mais aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que d'autres commencent à dire
bah finalement bon débrida ils sont
partis mais moi j'étais un peu d'accord
avec vous je suis pas spécialement
autre problème le refus d'autres front
de contestation on commence à voir
apparaître dans les dossiers adressés
pour tous oublié de faire des majorités
pour s'opposer parce qu'un grand pays
est parti mais on risque de voir là des
choses équivalente à émerger merci c'est
l'heure du checkpoint le checkpoint de
thomas mignon cette semaine thomas a
disséqué la déclaration françois fillon
lors du premier débat qui s'est tenu sur
tf1 dans la campagne présidentielle
française
il disait la majorité des réfugiés sont
des hommes et des femmes qui fuient la
pauvreté checkpoints et tout de suite
réfugiée aux migrants économiques
cette distinction est devenu un argument
politique lors du débat à la
présidentielle française françois fillon
a soulevé la question mais l'immense
majorité de ces réfugiés sont en réalité
des hommes et des femmes qui fuient la
pauvreté selon lui une majorité serait
donc des migrants guy économique et de
qui parle-t-on
d'abord françois fillon n'a pas utilisé
le bon terme un réfugiés fuient la
guerre il a donc droit à l'asile
quant aux migrants son pays n'est pas en
guerre mais il décide de le quitter pour
améliorer sa vie pour une meilleure
éducation par exemple selon ces
définitions de l'onu un migrant ne peut
donc pas être assimilé à un réfugié
d'ailleurs si l'on regarde les demandes
d'asile enregistrées en europe
en 2016 1 million 250 mille les migrants
semble d'emblée minoritaires ce sont
essentiellement des personnes issues de
pays en guerre syriens afghans irakiens
représentent à eux seuls 50 e pour cent
des demandes sans aller plus loin on
peut déjà conclure que plus de la moitié
ont en théorie bel et bien droit au
statut de réfugié mais alors combien
sont les migrants impossible à dire
ni l'union européenne ni l'eau ni ne
sont parvenus à établir de statistiques
claires et fiables concernant les
migrants économiques un facteur peut
toutefois nous donner un indice
le taux d'acceptation des demandes
d'asile en 2011 seuls 33% des personnes
entrées clandestinement en italie ou en
grèce
les principaux points d'entrée vers
l'europe ont obtenu l'asile
quatre ans plus tard on approche des 76
%
cela signifierait qu aujourd'hui la
grande majorité d'entre eux sont
effectivement bien les réfugiés
les chiffres manquent mais dire qu'une
immense majorité des réfugiés fuient la
pauvreté c'est contestable
[Musique]
voilà c'est contestable et merci à tous
de nous avoir éclairé donc sur ce débat
rendez vous la semaine prochaine à
strasbourg pour un autre pour une autre
émission on se penchera cette fois sur
la présidentielle française vue par les
députés européens étrangers merci à tous
très belle semaine ciao
[Musique]